we are your local election headquarters
and eight news now investigator David
charns joining us now with the latest
totals in these big races David yeah
Brian Denise so we will have a new
governor come January Governor Joe
Lombardo this is oh that check mark just
appearing on screen in the last couple
of minutes there I was going to do one
myself but here's how Joe Lombardo got
there you see our state here with those
blue and red counties here in Clark
County where Sheriff Lombardo is Sheriff
he was trailing Governor sisilak by Five
Points up in Washoe County was tied now
keep in mind Governor sisilak became
Governor sisalak by winning here in
Clark County by 13 points you see here
Joe Lombardo winning this race by about
20 000 votes with more to count all eyes
though on us tonight with this race the
senate race and that is because Senator
Catherine Cortez masto is trailing Adam
laxal former Attorney General Adam laxle
by 800 votes yeah 800 votes is what
we're talking about here and the reason
why this race hasn't been caught
involved is because there are so many
outstanding votes those mail-in votes
that are being processed my colleague
Vanessa Murphy about to talk about that
here in Clark County now Catherine
Cortez masto is leading here by seven
points and her lead will only grow as
mail-ins tend to skew towards Democrats
the voting we got today from Clark
County added 27 000 votes in total about
it was two to one margin for Catherine
Cortez masto quickly here all of our
house races have now been called Dina
Titus winning her race we told you that
earlier in the day Susie Lee winning her
race here 52 percent to 48 to April
Becker and Steven Horsford winning his
race by about the same margin there in a
district four so come January there will
be a new governor here in Nevada
Governor Joe Lombardo Denise